christoph christina thomas
du für uns setzen bitteschön dank
klingen schon
einfach so die freie version heißt eine
open-air garten version und woran
erkenne ich die dass man dass das stellt
aber nicht dran aber was ist denn das
frei luftiger an diese werden sie im
garten aufgenommen und da hört man vögel
haben dass er in zwei jahren aufgenommen
war ja einmal im studio ganz normaler wo
alles still ist und dir das instrument
einzelnen aufgenommen worden sind einmal
wir im garten gesessen sind dann haben
vögel zwitschern und ein praktisch
vorbei gefahren und man ganz genau wird
man dann auch und dann halt eingespielt
auf einmal gesagt du hast schon so
sensationell wir sind mitten im gespräch
weil
darf ich die unverstellte frage stelle
direkt am anfang schon eine unverschämte
fragen wer ist denn auch bibel knackte
idee gekommen dass draußen mit traktoren
geräusche und so zu machen ach naja dann
wird sind der traktor war ja nicht klar
gekommen oder war eigentlich so dass wir
die production gemacht haben das heißt
die vorproduktion eigentlich alle
nummern die wir aufnehmen wollten dann
mal angeguckt haben welche tonhöhe wie
ich hatte die form der nummer und so und
dann das war april na ja und dann war
hat ein schöner tag und wir wollten
nicht in den keller gehen ins studios
und dann haben wir gesagt krise egal
damit man mal die form checken von der
anderen nummer machen wir das doch
draußen sitzt gerade nach dem
mittagessen es war draußen schön es war
sonne material troika frühling schön
lass uns das doch 1000 abchecken und
dann haben wir draußen gespielt und
haben wir darum herum probieren und dann
hat der produzent gemeint nicht was das
nehmen wir doch jetzt einfach so auf ja
und dann haben wir unsere lieben
techniker die zufällig auch da waren
gefragt und sie uns beim verkabeln
helfen und damit dann vom keller auf die
ganz lampen kabel gelegt und alle sind
haben direkt aufgenommen und es hat
sogar 100 album geschafft hat ist ihr
habt zwei versionen es gibt diese
version also das ist diese freiluft
version die die da drauf ist da nur
warum genau warum heißt der song das ist
die normale studioversion
instrumente einzeln aufgenommen im
stillen raum
und dann gibt es noch eine version steht
aber warum freiluft versicherung dabei
und das ist die in unserem garten naja
ok das ist genau das ist immer so ein
bonustrack nicht also keine ahnung wo
sie drauf ist und wo sie nicht drauf ist
aber ich gebe es auf alle fälle als
download und es könnte es könnte ein
versteckter tracker gibt
wir haben beim letzten album hidden
track habt und das ist immer sehr
schwierig das ist schon ein bisschen
die puste ja das ist eine coole idee
natürlich super
so sieht dann schreibt dass nämlich das
ja und vor allem dann ist meine
handtasche bis das komische ding da weiß
ich nichts was man aber alles andere war
meine handtasche drinnen wenn man kommt
ja dann noch ein paar dazu ja okay das
ist so mein laufen der anstellung
das ist so ein laufband also das ist
dann immer wie lange ich glaube dass man
ja ja ja genau das sind drogen dem
norden her ist ihr einfluss war dass man
das auch ein baum war so wie abi band
passt von der natur dann die pole holte
schuldig gemacht haben ich stehe total
auf $ oder fendi ist ja jetzt wieder ja
total geil ich finde es super und dass
man so
was foto genau diese komischen in der
sendung warum steht hier töchter laufen
an das hat wiederum mit diesem laufbahn
ich bewahren habe ich gerade ich glaube
ein oder zwei tage vorher bei uns in
wien der frauenlauf wiener frauen noch
umgehauen wird genau oder können nur
frauen mit laufen wie der name schon
sagt und da
kann man fünf oder zehn kilometer laufen
ich bin mit einer freundin die auch
musikerin ist fünf kilometer gelaufen
und dem tag und wir sind dabei so ein
lauf community die nennt sich also das
loben von dieser neuen community heißt
töchter laut club der töchter und das
war so ein getränk geboren ein frühstart
so und was ist das hier das sieht auch
ein buch noch aus nein das ist ein bus
ohne von zeit tun samstagszeitung die
beilage gewählt weil er keine werbung
machen also okay ich war so einen tollen
kreuzung das ist so eine seite von di 10
samt es eng stärkste lizenz an das
ärgste das ist dezent dezent die zähne
18 das ärgste leicht dezent
sind das ist jetzt so vielleicht auch
wieder im wiener akzent oder ich bin als
laie ist das wienerisch oder ist das
österreichisch einmal unter schnitt um
zwei sitze ich wieder im taxi der taxler
sagt die cent sondern das ärgste
dezent meinte natürlich ja wir mal die
sind weil wegen der wechseln
die zentrale als ärgste
ob das ist direkt wienerisch ist es
österreich spricht das ärgste
total weil manchmal läuft ja in der ard
der wiener tatort ja und ich verstehe
manchmal gar nichts mehr weil die so
wienerisch sprechen mich zwar auch in
denen sie also in so einfach ist es aber
auch wenn ich berlin da gehöre ich falle
immer so rein das macht schon spaß wenn
sie denn so eine klingende sprache ist
aber manchmal verstehe ich da nichts
aber das geht mir noch auf oft
also nein wienerisch geht das natürlich
aber bei uns österreich nahm besteht aus
mehreren ländern unter anderem auch
vorab werk gehört zu uns und da redet
man xiii bärisch und
das verstehe ich manchmal auch nicht als
das kürzere österreich sind auch ihre
liebe menschen aber ich verstehe
manchmal bringt okay gut dann bin ich
ganz klar also das ist keine sorge auch
wir in unserem land verstehen uns manche
sehr schön sehr schön gut also nicht
sehr schön aber das ist eine multi kulti
aus urzeiten pass auf jetzt werden schon
viele youtuber sauer sein warum weil ich
eine frage noch nicht gestellt hat und
ich stelle mich immer die gleiche frage
am anfang und der antrag ist schon fast
vorbei aber trotzdem stellen wie ist die
lage
wie ist die lage wenn wir kurze - wie
kurz überlegen lassen
heute ist mit
wie ist die lage neun tage wien und da
sage ich jetzt mal so sagt man das nicht
so beim bundesheer lage neun tage ach so
ja in neun tagen bin ich endlich wieder
man zu hause so und jetzt bist du
unterwegs jetzt wenn ich ständig
unterwegs sind bewegten unterwegs heute
ist was anderes das fragen ja nein gar
nicht gar schon auch diese alles
mögliche aber die meisten pflanzen die
schon bei diesem thema ja weil es ist ja
das ist ja arbeit was er macht das
vergessen ja viele das ist wirklich so
morgens aufstehen wecker klingelt ich
muss zur arbeit und dann interview da
interview das macht ja auch spaß aber
man ist viel unterwegs was auch schön
ist trotzdem freut man sich dann immer
besonders auf zu hause vor allem wenn
man daneben längere zeit unterwegs sind
jetzt zum einen in vielen promo tour
natürlich unterwegs wegen dem neuen
album was ja schön ist aber in neun
tagen bin ich wieder mal zu hause jetzt
ständig unterwegs schweiz und
deutschland so und dann neun tagen darf
ich wieder meinen garten begutachten und
gucken ob mehr los schon im haus herum
schwirrt schon wieder staubsaugen muss
oder nicht hast du habt ihr das bei dir
im garten aufgenommen ja also nicht das
ganze allein aber dieses diese diese aus
draußen ja bei uns zu hause ist das in
bergen oder ist es
ich finde es hier bringe dass jeder
immer glaubt dass österreich nur das
berge besteht jede österreich liefern
können uns juden können damit nicht zu
billig möchte mit diesen vorurteilen
jetzt auch wenn ich in der schweizer ich
war ja auch als kind in der schweiz auf
dem gelände da waren immer berge ich
weiß und man landet auf dem flughafen
und schwarz und da fängt schon an adams
von juden in der schweiz ist in der
schweiz in österreich zum glück nationen
die ja mama ganz schlimm naja aber und
schonen sie nicht es ist auf alle fälle
so dass
österreich eben tirol zum beispiel in
österreich ist hat natürlich sehr sehr
viele berger das ist wirklich schön dort
auch da wo ich jetzt wohnen es ist
niederösterreich sondern nähe von wien
da gibt es schon berge aber jetzt nicht
so wie man sich das vielleicht der
deutsche vorstellt also dass richter
auch oft irgendwie so
wie in niederösterreich
das könnte hier wieder ist reich sein
hier sieht man ja nix das ist es gar
nicht als superflach das könnte
burgenland aber auch genau wunder nicht
so ganz leicht und da wo ich wohne das
ist das weinviertel und da gibt es dann
in das waldviertel über und da fand
sondern mit den bergen aber die sind
schon in rufweite juden muss man
wirklich sehr laut aber nein also da
sind wo ich wohne sind ein paar berg
laien und aber viele weit vor allem darf
man das aufgenommen aber jetzt noch mal
zur arbeit das machst du seit wieviel
jahren jetzt wann hast du angefangen
2000 noch
2003 etwas geld seiner stehen sitzen das
ist ihr weg was man aber sagen das ist
eine schlechte ergossen ach das sagt man
geld sind stehe ja die idee dass dann
nämlich blöden morgen das schwert sie
übrigens morgen ist nämlich dann sind da
ja das sieht ja nicht gut also morgen
habe ich kein interview es ist nicht so
schlimm also nochmal zu arbeiten wir
kommen die zu arbeiten
2003 war es jetzt 2002 habe ich
mitgemacht 2003 war dann die castingshow
irgendwo ich zeit genommen also jetzt
sieben jahre
arbeit kriegt man dann nicht irgendwann
denkt man ich muss jetzt mal den job
wechseln
nein also das habe ich mir noch kein
einziges mal gedacht am anfang
vielleicht wo ich mir gedacht hab
manchmal gleich das alte leben zurück
wünschen so ein bisschen ruhe das mich
nicht jeder mensch kennen darf der staat
oder sind nicht so viel autogramme
schreiben muss
anders gewirkt sich aber ich glaube es
hat jeder mensch in seinem job als
sachen die einem mehr spaß machen die
halt weniger spaß machen und manchmal
ist es anstrengend und manchmal nichts
anstrengendes hat bei dem beruf den ich
aus über auch und was ich aber sagen das
ist das halt ich habe hat mein hobby zum
beruf machen also ich kann mich das war
ehemann habe ich habe mit zwölf oder
dreizehn begonnen band zu spielen
saxophon und querflöte und hab dann mit
1516 zum ersten mal dass ich dann hinter
das mikrofon durfte singen durfte das
hat uns sehr gut gefallen und
das war echt immer schon was was mir
irre viel spaß gemacht hat und somit
kann ich mich echt nur wird lagen also
das wird natürlich manchmal dass es
anstrengend aber
und hat man manchmal auch angst und zwar
angst davor weil das ist ein total
empfindet diesen organen und man kennt
weiß was ich stefanie 1 sonja seine
schweizer kollegen plötzlich weg das ist
ja echt hat man da manchmal angst wo ich
meine wenn so ein kalter zu vorbeikommt
und man hängt das ist das ende
also ich hab mit stefanie heinzmann kurz
darüber geredet das ist richtig scheiße
muss man sagen nicht also wenn man da
vor allem lahmgelegte tour absagen muss
das ist echt nicht schön gar nicht ich
habe bis jetzt ein konzert abgesagt eben
wegen stimmband
und das hat mir schon so wäre dann
einfach menschen nach hause zu schicken
die da weiß ich nicht vielleicht 300
kilometer gefahren sind und dann wenn
man so geht nicht stimme weg
ich muss gestehen ich habe vor fünf
jahren aufgehört zu rauchen also das war
mal das erste was ich gemacht habe und
ich schaue einfach mehr auf mich also
ich schon wenn es dann kalt ist dass ich
nicht unbedingt auch vor herumlaufen
oder sonst irgendwas dass ich dann immer
auch wenn ihr honig oder irgend sowas
dabei habe immer so ein bisschen stimme
ölen aber so richtig extreme angst habe
ich ehrlich gesagt nicht also ich habe
noch nie so eine mega problem damit
gehabt man sich ja doch sein ja also
noch nie so eine richtige als entzündung
mit kann ja so ich kenne sie kann man
halt echt ja ich war im winter im chor
ich singen im chor und dann sind sind
die da alle mit den tröpfchen und alle
diese ich muss auch immer sagen also was
ganz super es ist thomas rezept ja erst
wenn der bisher schlecht geht also
gekühlt oder so dann mit schnaps nein ja
also früchtetee vielleicht mit obstler
oder schnaps das ist super also das
wärmt von innen klar und dann halt
sofort rein ins bett zu denken und
schwitzt man hat sehr viel aber das ist
und die bakterien abgetötet menschen
welches stück
gefällt dir jetzt am besten also wir
leben den moment hören wir jetzt sehr
oft ist das auch mein lieblingsstück
oder ist das
wie ist das wenn man also mein
lieblingsstück ist es nicht wenn man so
ein album herausbringt dann wechselt das
sehr oft an den songs die gerade am
besten gefallen
dann ist es gerade so war supergut wird
nochmal einseitigen allein singen
und wenn man das nächste stück sondern
weil man sich zu herzen nimmt dann ist
es auch einmal das deshalb muss ich
gestehen wir leben den moment ist eine
schöne nummer klar ist unsere erste
single die höre ich habe im moment
natürlich sehr und wir spielen sie sehr
oft aber
oder fendt dass es schönere nummern wie
gut das willst aber noch nicht verraten
gut wer hat man vielleicht so
liebesbeziehungen mit den titeln die man
auf dem album hat also im sinne von ich
kann dich nicht mehr sehen und
komm her ich will dich noch zehn mal
singen
lustigerweise schon also das ist aber
echt beim einzigen dass der ball dann
weil du dann merkst das macht total viel
spaß oder da kann man sich vorher
einfallen lassen auch
taktzeiten so das ist echt wir haben
jetzt sehr sehr viel eingesungen am
abend und was schon dunkel mit einem
gläschen wein vielleicht in der hand und
dann hat geradezu balladen oder
ruhigeren nummern mann der oberhammer
der hätte ich glaube ich hundertmal
einsehen können der produzent der olaf
opal da hätte glaube ich auch hundertmal
gerne zugehört sind alle müssen
ach so
schön
und dann war da war nach drei mal
einzigen im kasten dann sowieso ja
eigentlich hamas also wenn du möchtest
kannst du schon noch mal ein jahr her
damit
also es hat echt spaß gemacht aber
natürlich hat man einfach zu manchen
songs die sich mal lieber
oder öfter und andere songs sind machen
zwar ihre ersparnis sind aber
anstrengender zu singen vielleicht wird
es ein rockiger session dann merkt man
hat schon dass es nach fünf mal ein
singen und das so dass einfach die
stimme hat
ein spannendes wärme anfang und dann
merkt man auch das ist eigentlich nichts
mehr bringt und das ist eigentlich schon
im kasten lesen auch wenn es noch spaß
gemacht würde man sich vielleicht nur
die stimme kaputt machen also dass er
wahrscheinlich kann ich mir auch
vorstellen dass oft auch nummern gerade
wenn man selber singt ja nummern
vielleicht die lieblingsnummern sind die
beim publikum gar nicht sagen kommen
weil man ja einen ganz anderen zugang
dazu hat
ja das ist auch oft so also das finde
ich sehr spannend weil beim letzten
album zum beispiel bin jetzt schon
gespannt münster als beim letzten album
habe ich mir noch die mega hammer und li
na ja wir ja alles okay aber es gefällt
mir nicht so gut und lustig dann sind
auf einmal hergekommen die fans ja man
spielte diese nummer endlich mal live
und ich hab
das ist die die mir eigentlich am
wenigsten gefällt komisch eigentlich und
deshalb bin ich jetzt schon gespannt was
da ist ob da auch das komplett
auseinander geht das ist ja geschmäcker
sind verschieden ist halt so und deiner
findet das toll und der andere das und
das
das trennt sich halt irgendwie deshalb
bin ich gespannt ob wir uns da irgendwo
treffen
ihr lieben leute und ich in die band
oder ob da wieder da einer das toll
findet und ich habe das mal ganz anderes
bin schon gespannt jetzt zum schluss
aber wir sehen ja schon ein bisschen
eingestiegen wir müssen noch mal
unbedingt bolivarische boulevard ich
werde der boulevard ist also gewohnt
sind im haus ich nehme an mit einem
freund zusammen wie lange wollt ihr denn
noch zu zweit bleiben
du weißt genau was ich meine wir
überlegen jetzt wieder das umschiffen
frage wie kann ich diese frage jetzt
nicht so beantworten würde
wie du sie gemeint hast also wir wollen
natürlich noch lange zu zweit bleiben
also wir wollen also das heißt zurzeit
ich möchte noch lange mit ihm zusammen
sein ja okay da wenn es geht bis in mein
leben zu gehen will wie lange darf ich
fragen wie lange seite schon vier jahre
vier
jahren ein häuschen und im garten und
dann ist es super also das kann frage
und weil du ja natürlich auf ein huhn
oder so aus wie nun wollte ich immer
schon haben das habe ich einfach kann es
zeit nicht also das ist so
was sondern bist du auf tue man werde wo
man sie kroos mit die techniker dann hat
der 120 verschiedene herrchen jeder sagt
etwas anderes dass er würden wir noch
gerne längere zeit zu zweit und bleiben
ohne hund war aber was ja so ähnlich
immer mit kindern die haben sich
ja aber jetzt nicht ich finde ich
irgendwie noch nicht so mama rita
paß auf es ist immer falsch theft ist es
immer die falsche zeit es ist immer
falsch so was kann man nicht so gut kam
auch nicht mehr ich glaube man sollte
auch nicht klar also ich bin das kann
man nicht planen wenn es soweit ist dann
ist soweit und da ist dann eigentlich
auch scheißegal mal ehrlich sind ob da
jetzt kein album raus ist oder nicht wir
sind helfen zb schönes beispiel der mit
zwei kinder und haben jetzt auch ein
album gehen auch auf tour also es ist
alles unter einen hut zu kriegen ich
habe ein super gipfel ging man muss es
aus dem bauch heraus machen
grünig der carla okay vielen dank es war
sehr aufschlussreich spannend in die
hand lustig und zoll super danke
vergessen